do you guys want for me okay
what's up dis is lil nas ex and I'm
going undercover on the Internet it's
actually me Twitter I love this
[Music]
Caroline Benison says without sounding
like I'm completely knocked down with
the kids but why does little nas ex
calls someone up panini
panini is a character from a TV show
called chowder and she was like madly in
love with chowder on the show she
represents like fans who love you when
you're small but like don't love you
when you get to like a certain height of
success pretty much post it velvet dark
says why does Lunas having eggs is this
like a final fantasy thing that I missed
in nine previous versions at will nas
yeah I'm gonna 10th version of a little
nas and when they were making us in the
factory you just you just came out this
way next bro how this little nas ex have
better media training than Scarlett
Johansson do I have a good media
training I didn't know I thought I was
pretty terrible in interviews actually
but uh thank you sorry Scarlett Avery
says Lunas ex you on Jeopardy tonight
how does it feel to be this famous I was
on Jeopardy
I didn't know I was on Jeopardy I'm glad
to go with that or something like that
intricate expenses says sir how does it
feel to be a drummer breaking hero that
refuses to be pigeonholed into modern
societies neat little behavioral boxes
oh my god they really meant that I don't
like this question it feels great though
high power says little knives and
scissor y'all down for a clap of course
posted this is a 1-8 you up after this
and we're gonna work on something
next up Instagram web ball Billy Ray
Cyrus wants you to remix all so what
brings the country vibe grad single love
needed somebody who's gonna kill the
remix and Billy Ray Cyrus's did that
next which artists influenced you to
pursue slash kick off your musical
career who loves to collaborate with
next no specific artists actually like
inspired me to start making music but I
would like to collaborate with you know
a lot of different artists like Drake of
course Rico nasty always mentioned her
ski mask hmm
the baby again maybe like a real
original song next okay we need a skin
routine hop in the bed and fall asleep
pretty much you know wash your face in
the morning I don't know I do what I can
post it who's the most shocking
unexpected person that reached out to
you in support
besides Billy Ray that will have to be
hmm maybe uh maybe like Justin Bieber
like posting the song when his story for
us like glowing that maybe yeah yeah
this is by 3d blood he's like yo NAS did
you ever get a little Lucy feature for
panini the fans want to know I did not
receive who is his verse maybe in the
future but not sad sad sad sad okay
Quorra this old town roll by lil
Nozick's a country song yes it is also a
hip hop song it is a country trap song
it is both yes how does little Nozick's
make money nas makes Ong Bak horse nas
make song about sandwich money come
did Billy Ray Cyrus helpful Nozick's yes
or no yes boom did little Isaac's create
a new genre did he invent country trap
music I'm not the inventor I don't take
credit but you know yes it's here and I
have something to do with it maybe it's
little nas X capable of redefining
American music culture will see him 10
years was Kevin Hart rule two little nas
ex and HBO's to shop uninterrupted I
don't think Kevin was intentionally you
know rude or anything
he said nice things do you think the NAS
X can sing without auto-tune let's see
whoa
oh yeah that's pretty good
the answer is yes Wikipedia he began
playing trumpet in the fourth grade and
it was first chair by his junior high
years but quit out of fear looking
uncool this this is true this is true
thought you can still play you know
reddit did learn Isaac's delete the
original Old Town Road version from
YouTube yes I did
in fear of copyright that's it signing
off the internet
closes laptop